how many of those sons of [ __ ] do you
have vw buses
way too many man i probably would have
been better off with a cocaine habit but
no
i've got somewhere along the lines of 20
between 20 and 25
buses
do you buy them and then like refurbish
them and sell them or once you got it
you got it for life
uh i haven't sold any of them uh what i
what i did in the beginning was
um i was working with the jay leno's car
guys
uh same guys that work with um seinfeld
and so
they were like hey whatever you need
just let us know and i had no idea they
were that quick
like you give them a specific year color
everything and they just
here you go yeah and then i'll be like
oh shoot sorry i got doggies
anyway that's what i did in the
beginning and then i i met uh someone
who actually does
car restoration but his specialty is
volkswagen
oh wow and he just uh he says
tell me what year what color we'll pimp
it out and
that's how i do the cars now great [ __ ]
dude i bought a 1974
vw bus and i brought it in the mechanic
he's like dude why the [ __ ] did you buy
this
and and i was like i don't know i just
i've always wanted to drive one
dude every week every [ __ ] week that
thing broke down i'm like scott
dude how are we supposed to get anything
[ __ ] done when he can't drive
anywhere
dude i would be like having like all i'd
be picking up workers to help us work or
something you know
and then all of a sudden like i have to
call triple a get them towed we'd all
jump in an uber and get to go to the
house and finish work i mean
every [ __ ] time i got in that car
like my aaa membership just like
expired or you know i used it all up
yeah if you have a
volkswagen whether it's a car bus thing
or karman ghia
uh you're you're gonna have those days
where uh you put your key in and all
you're doing is just putting your key in
[Music]
yeah they're much better in a showroom
never driven
just parked there to look at yeah yeah
do you drive them around ever gabriel
i'll take them out but i mean i'll keep
them in the neighborhood i'll keep them
in the vicinity
yeah stay close yeah you're redoing all
the engines and you're still keeping it
in the neighborhood like i was
i was going everywhere you know that was
my main commuter
yeah if it's a daily driver you got to
really stay on top of it uh
my suggestion because it is a 1974. i'm
having a 1974 right now
uh i'm doing a little conversion where
i'm having that
that engine taken out and i'm replacing
it with a subaru
engine it's going to have like 180
horsepower which is insane
and it's going to be a very dependable
daily driver and it's also going to have
air conditioning
[ __ ] so you'd feel confident driving
that thing every day all day
oh yeah that that car will be a
completely diff it's not even a
volkswagen as far as i'm concerned it's
you know stop thinking about it
yeah dude